how many people a year do you think get
their arms cut off in a baylor baylor i
hardly know her damn it Michael pay
attention anybody want to take a guess
five bucks says it's over 50 you really
want to bet anybody ever since March
Madness ended I am so bored how many
okay ten people Michael
ten people would you like to be one of
them
no don't be a loser double or nothing
these are very dangerous machines down
here and the upstairs workers Michael
should not go anywhere near them yes yes
but it wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world won't be the worst thing in
the world it would I got it only on the
rarest of occasions okay ten really ten
that's your guess you're a professional
accountant there's a ten green ones
forty-two I'm gonna say 50 51 oh come on
that is like the strategy it's called
being smart thank you
I don't know how the whole betting thing
started but it's fun though damn it 48
49 Oh
he's not there he spent hours up here at
reception with you hours and hours okay
okay no constantly like for years okay
the top of the queue so number five
becomes number four number six becomes
number five number three becomes number
two etc etc and let's just say that I
just sent back Love Actually which was
awesome and they sent me uptown girls
which is also awesome but guess what now
I want to see Love Actually again but
it's at the bottom of the queue oh no
what do I do what I do is this I go
online I go click click click and I
changed the order of the queue so I can
see Love Actually as soon as I want to
it's so easy Ryan do you really not know
how Netflix works I guess I forgot
Ryan well done two minutes 42 seconds
additionally Pam you went 10 because she
said awesome 12 times and Jim you win 5
because she mentioned 6 romantic
comedies
greed is eating in Temple I found a
potato
I don't know this place as well as I
thought I did I'm getting close
you